m
la première édition du challenge thierry
grimaux s'est déroulée ce samedi 30
avril au dojo régional du champ fleuri
si un événement pour rendre hommage de
son vivant à thierry grimaux judokas au
palmarès impressionnant fois médaillé
aux jeux des îles de l'océan indien j'ai
fait depuis 98 et après j'étais en
équipe de france cadets juniors seniors
mais aujourd'hui fait des titres au
niveau national et international et j'ai
fini par le jury dessus combat il avait
fait deux camps jeux mondiaux et 3e aux
championnats du monde et comment aux
europe
voilà en gros
naughty palmarès 250 jeunes de
différents clubs de l'huile se sont
affrontés sur le tatami lors d'un
tournoi pour lequel le prix en jeu sont
simon nous de vivre ensemble de partage
un challenge pour véhiculer les valeurs
de citoyenneté de courage et honnêteté
porté par thierry guinot nous thierry
grimaux c'est l'incarnation c'est un
exemple réunionnais un des meilleurs
exemples réunionnais de la citoyenneté
et de la possibilité de l'ascenseur
social c'est quelqu'un qui vient d'un
milieu très modeste il est issu d'un
quartier qui est le quartier du chaudron
et ce quartier produit on en parle trop
peu
sans doute mais parmi les plus grandes
réussites et notamment sportives de ce
pays il a mené aussi une carrière
d'éducateur tout ce qu'il a pu apprendre
tout au long de sa carrière il n'a eu de
cesse de leur transmettre aux plus
jeunes aux jeunes de son quartier
d'autres quartiers aux jeunes de l'île à
travers son poste d'entraîneur au pôle
espoir alors transmettant du savoir de
la technicité du judoka mais aussi des
valeurs et ces valeurs sont celles qui
font de la citoyenneté la solidarité
l'entr'aide la progrès de la prospérité
mutuelle le respect la compréhension la
politesse pour le département partenaire
de cet événement thierry grimaud a
marqué l'histoire du sport réunionnais
et doit devenir un modèle de citoyenneté
pour la jeunesse
la collectivité a mis en place plusieurs
dispositifs pour accompagner les jeunes
sportifs vers leur réussite
le département j'ai en oeuvre une
politique volontariste pour accompagner
nos jeunes et principalement sur cette
mandature nous accompagnons
tous les jeunes de 12 à 25 ans parce que
c'est important d'être là de les aider à
rencontrer d'autres sportifs de la zone
océan indien du monde de l'europe et
donc nous on vient d accompagner sur le
dispositif donc d'accompagnement à la
mobilité sur les projets sportifs et
aussi on est là sur le sportif
accompagné le sportif de haut niveau à
travers les bourses à travers tout un
dispositif qui remplace de grandes
institutions étaient également présents
lors de cette manifestation la police
nationale et le service départemental
d'incendié et de secours de la réunion
ont assuré des ateliers afin de créer
des vocations et d'informer sur les
métiers proposés par les services
publics mais sapeurs-pompiers sont une
des voix qui permettent effectivement
véhiculer ses valeurs donc pour se
donner un but dans la vie ça peut
commencer plus tôt chez certains au
niveau des jeunes sapeurs pompiers ou
travers des actions qui sont même mises
en place par l'union départementale des
sapeurs-pompiers de la réunion mais
aussi par un engagement de sapeurs
pompiers volontaires
c'est bien d'être confrontés au
quotidien des interventions et puis pour
certains peut-être qu'ils puissent en
faire leur métier
c'est un fabuleux ascenseur social c'est
ce qu'il faut c'est de la volonté on
peut effectivement travaillé aussi un
peu à l'école et je dis ça pour les
jeunes mais pas uniquement donc il ya
vraiment un engagement de soi
au profit de l'ensemble de la population
par cet engagement citoyen ce challenge
a été l'occasion de rendre hommage aux
grands champions thierry grimaud qui
désormais passe le flambeau à la jeune
génération